and here at home a special ceremony was  held to shine a light on nevada's aging  population  personal care workers joined advocates  to light up signs this happened near  sahara and rancho tonight  their message is that home care is  essential  today is a national day of action as  workers highlight president biden's  plans to invest billions of dollars into  home and community-based services  with joe biden's plan with all the  structure we'll be able to  take care of our clients with the  highest pro care possible we'll be able  to have  the wages that we need we'll be able to  have the health care benefits that we  need  it's a necessary thing that needs to  happen in nevada and across the nation  there are some 13 thousand home care  workers in nevada  and the average pay is 11 dollars an  hour the study from the gwen center  shows that nevada will need at least  5 thousand more workers in the next five  years